Layout dependent on the size of my browser,
right? What happens if I rotate my phone?
>> If the dimensions of the layout viewpoint
change, the browser has to rerun the layout
step. That's what happens every time you rotate
your phone or, for that matter, resize your browser.
>> Hm, I see. So our examples are pretty
simple but could this possibly a performance bottle neck?
>> Yep, let's take a look at their tools. I've captured a trace of gizmodo.com
which is a popular new site. If you're curious you can grab this trace from
the instructor notes and follow along. Let's take
a look. First of all, there's a turn
of events here. Since we're only interested
in layout, let's filter out the loading, scripting,
and painting events. Okay, here's the first layout
event. Check it out. It took 145 milliseconds.
>> Wow! That's a long time.
>> Yeah, as you can see there are over 1400 nodes. In the tree.
>> Huh. but there are other layout events in here. What's going on?
>> That's a great question. Recall that
any time we update the render tree, either
by modifying styles or the content, there's
a good chance we have to rerun layout.
And in this case, it looks like
that's exactly what's happening. The page is adding
new content and modifying styles, and hence, we
need to run layout a few more times.
>> Hm. I see. So how do you go about optimizing for that?
>> It really depends on the site, but a good rule
of thumb is to batch updates to avoid having multiple layout events.